leading the NBA in points scored or
assisted on per game donchic fade away
three
is good
Luca matchup hunting wants to get Drew
holiday off of him and goes to that
patented Ryan ruko JJ Redick rose gold
on wood a with you
Luka doncic off to a hot start and
continuing it here what he's doing right
now to this bucks defense against Great
Defenders like Drew holiday can't be
overstated
is in after the sauce from donchic Luca
using the body to get him off and then
just the beautiful behind the back pass
and cleba able to knock
here's Carter stolen by Dodges could be
fun
as well
[Applause]
Luca orchestrating and manipulating the
half court but in transition he's got
some bunnies
ducking on Drew holiday of all people
[Music]
using the screen backing away one on one
with Lopez got
credit
for the lead
the go ahead layup
Luca gets the matchup he wants on Lopez
uses the threat of that step back going
left to cry that makes up for not
bombing threes and getting you to 30 at
night here's Luca at the end of the
quarter by Robinson Earl and still make
something good happen
Jeremiah Robinson Earl is the defender
Luca rocking the dribble back and forth
working oh
[Applause]
did he Smith screens Lucas splits a
double team gets way down deep
[Applause]
answering Shea kill just Alexander's
three-point play Luca can do the same
thing
when he puts that thing on the deck
hanging takes the bump or the foul I
want you to hang in there he's so strong
he is then on a heater in the first half
until then huh Luca nice move through
traffic what a pass and the three is
made by Timothy Dwayne Hardaway I don't
think anybody in the ring will solved
that pass that Luca made
that was ridiculous
call Dallas over the lemon now
a quarter look at that it's a nice look
how did he even have the angle for that
that's craziness
I mean there is a big guy
offensive numbers have been superb for
Portland recently and winning five of
the last six games because it's in what
he caught a three and one of the best of
the Fizz this year and hitting Corner
threes is Spencer deadwoody we got a
special interview coming up to start the
second quarter JJ Berea is in the house
oh yeah Skin's going to talk to him for
a couple minutes at the start of the
quarter the first quarter and brother
Luca steps back Jack finds Hardaway
Maneuvers away from the closeout Luca
Maneuvers away from the horizon
[Applause]
[Music]
it's real nice
been a timeout call but we ain't going
nowhere we're gonna let you look at this
again a time or two then D'Angelo
Russell is shooting splits both from
Deep at The Rim finishing like that and
from mid-range he's always been a good
mid-range jump shooter
it's all good about mindset for Russell
as dances
Dodge it's the step back to his left
that's what you're trying to get him
away from you do not want Luca Dunn
60-48. Edwards
turns it over
[Applause]
[Music]
dances finds Vinnie Smith Corner three
good
[Music]
victory
up ahead Hardaway
steps outside will fire and hit
[Music]
not just around the woods screen a
little no look Bullock in the corner and
he makes his first shot Rockets have
scored sixth straight they've made Seven
shots they've assisted on six of them
and there was a foul lunacy would see
some daylight Luke and just putting it
on the numbers there and Luca is
excellent passer
you catch him on a hot night you're in
deep trouble you catch him on a cold
night we're watching it right now
you saw Darvin ham there in his first
year as the head coach
left hand right hand off the glass now
it's nice to see donchick get in a
little bit of a Groove here and the
offense they just don't have enough
weapons with Davis out of the lineup oh
pretty Dodge hangs but can't finish got
the offensive rebound oh what a fake he
totally faked got Gabriel and then just
score this guy he has such incredible
patience now once it goes up so he's
following that shot he's going to go
down inside take the back now watch a
little ball Pig Defender looks he goes
right back up
just toying with winyan Gabriel see when
you're sitting at Courtside you make him
go back right I don't think it's as easy
nice play there
[Applause]
[Music]
nothing shocks me about this game and
that Drew rim
[Applause]
s
3.9 seconds left here's how it went down
[Applause]
[Music]
I mean but he was very physical with
chingon it was physical with everybody
yeah Luca drop step spin score as he
worked around Eric Gordon
he's got a piece for sure
a basket in the block to start the game
[Applause]
offensive foul as Shin goon left his
feet it's Dinwiddie into Luca yeah
this has a knack an uncanny ability to
seize the moment of an opportunity see
that one of two in the line for
Christian Wood eight is six here is so
Hand blocked by Luka doncic that's his
21st block of the Season he's become a
much better Defender this year as well
too yeah his patient there he kept his
feet didn't go for the fakes
and there's the step back that thing
went in and popped out right is that
what y'all was that was like the uh
James Harden did that in the game a few
years ago right
another three conclusion yes sir
you gotta stay engaged
[Applause]
oh and what a fancy pass for once
alley-u great finish but the pass woo
of Lucas four assists certainly the
prettiest
and wood what a night he's having 17
points
looking for an assist on a hearty
three-pointer that one was no good Luca
challenges that hurt Jones shot it's a
no call it's a missed basket and it's
Dallas headed the other way
unable to stay in front nearly we're
able to choke down some Canary feathers
and steal that game in Dallas
Unfortunately they couldn't hold on to
the base free throw in Dallas would
Prevail Dodge is back on the floor the
drive of the dish to Hardaway Junior for
the three back in February Leonard after
the miss
trying to take it to dodge it before the
double comes loses the ball and dinwiddy
controls now centers it to Dodge with a
couple of Defenders to beat gets right
to the rim and lays it in missing his
19th consecutive game
a foot injury
as donchic gets the whistle Dinwiddie on
his own and then Don shit's just great
footwork after picking up the dribble
that's what you'll put it in hasn't
scored since Midway through the third
Deadwood he gives it right back shooter
on Dodge three-pointer on its way for
the top
[Applause]
IC a punch three
time out Lakers decided not to double
dodge it like they have been the whole
second half to not open up other people
but that gives conscience a chance
hadn't had a bucket since the 522 Mark
of the third quarter and with six
seconds to go the game is tied Jeremy
Grant playing in isolation
look at Terence shakes two Defender for
laying it in the lookout from Lucas
effective
and here comes Luca into the front door
the Pella picks him up shot it right
over the top like he wasn't there
of the charge right there and then in
transition
Capella's matched up with him knocks
down the three
here's Powell hands it back to DeLuca 10
on the shot clock
step back three that's his spot and
that's the result that we often see
well again a little drop coverage the
step back going left
pretty solid defense by Martin it's just
a tremendous shot
if you look at his three-point
percentage
[Music]
got a hold of it launches it Hallelujah
just a great end to a terrific first
quarter
by Luca and the Mavericks at both ends
of the floor
please show me today
so two straight possessions with stops
[Music]
coming off an Orlando game where he went
over five for the floor he's on the
board and so is Luca with a difficult
shot that's his second make of the game
we're moving away from the bucket that's
very difficult attempt Luke able to
concentrate enough to get it down and
the smart thing is using it's always one
guy that really stretches up oh way up
and Luca
a moment of Luca magic to stop a run by
the way even KP recognizes you see
Luca's Rainmaker
he was really just trying to draw the
foul and had the presence to get the
shot up
I hit you one thing shot missed by Luca
offensive rebound to White Powell green
turned down to three made a walk past
boom shaka Luka he rises and jams it for
Luca Dodgers fellas not to my surprise a
little spin away from Hayes